réalisateur
Austin Butler Elvis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
Colin Farrell les Banshees d'Innishair
[Applaudissements]
tu étais gentil de ne jamais l'
être, oh mon Dieu,
peut-être que tu n'as jamais été
Brendan Fraser la baleine,
tu es un incroyable  personnalité,
je ne pourrais pas demander
de fille plus incroyable, est-ce que tu
essaies vraiment de me mettre en couple en ce moment,
vraiment,
qui voudrait que je fasse partie de leur
vie
[Musique]
Paul Maskel après le soleil
finira certainement par
venir où tu veux vivre  je
peux rencontrer qui tu veux être, tu as le
temps
[Musique]
Bill Nye vivant
Dieu est-ce
une erreur de fumée Je n'ai pas remarqué
ce que je devenais
et puis je me souviens de
ce que c'était d'être en vie
si j'avais besoin d'être en vie comme  que pour un
jour
et l'Oscar revient à
Brandon Fraser Brendan Fraser pour
Wayne
enfant Brendan
Brendan Fraser Oliver
[Applaudissements]
merci
donc voilà à quoi ressemble le Multivers
oh
mon Dieu euh
je remercie l'académie pour cette catégorie Académie
je
veux  je te dis que oui,
l'énergie est
étrangère,
merci